♪ Four and three and two and one
(humming triumphantly)
- My Lincoln Town Car.
- [Ilana] This is a Prius.
- I call it that because
my name is Lincoln,
and I'm gonna drive
around town in my car.
These all gotta come out.
- What?
- I'm just kidding.
(laughs)
- Is that Lincoln?
- Yep?
- Is he inside of you?
- Yep.
I really haven't
thought about it,
but I'd be Posh Spice.
- Oh, you're so Posh Spice.
- So, I'm gonna get
my own food truck.
I'm gonna call it
Lincoln's Center.
- That is genius.
- You think 'cause
you come in here
in your little short shorts,
looking all Idris Elba.
- Idris Elba?
- Oh, don't act
like you don't know.
You look like him.
- With great power comes
great responsibility.
- Teddy Roosevelt.
- Spider-Man.